okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel
today i'm doing my first call-in show
you guys are gonna have to bear with me
because
i just had somebody cancel for
a reaction video with me so i was like
you know what
let's see
i can get people to call in so i just
dropped the link in the chat
so basically what i would like is to
talk to women that disagree with me as
you know on this channel we bring around
women from blue pill to red pill and so
what i would like to do is talk to women
that maybe have an issue with something
i said or disagree with me bear with me
there might be tech issues this is my
first time doing a call-in show so we're
gonna see
how this works
um okay
let's see should i put this on the
screen
i don't use streamlabs too much
so um what are what are the issues that
people
have disagreed with me on the most
well there's a lot
one of them was i talk about
how it's disrespectful to get fat
if you're in a relationship if your
husband buys you at 120
and now you're 220
you don't think that's a little
disrespectful to your husband
they understand your body's gonna change
a little bit with kids okay
they they do all right that the men they
know this if you're at 120 you get to
140. most get most guys are gonna be
chill they're gonna be cool with it i
mean they're not gonna prefer it
right but they know you're gonna have
kids your body's gonna change a little
bit
but when you gain a hundred pounds
over the course of like five years
ma'am ma'am
anyways um that that one cost me a
couple friends they did not appreciate
that
i stand by it i stand by it what else
has gotten me into trouble on the
internet i'm just talking about things
that people can disagree with me on by
the way guys i put in um the link in the
chat i've never done a call-in show
well i used to i've never done a women
call-in show
so
i'm i'm just testing this out i i just
had this idea
i was supposed to film a video with
someone they kind of bailed so i was
like you know what
i'ma just
oh shoot sorry okay um pearl keep doing
what you're doing keep it up thank you
for the 20 super chat guys
these
these super chats are going towards
cameras i want to buy 15 000 worth of
cameras i know that's a huge number
okay i know you're like that's a stupid
amount of cameras but i really want to
get everyone's faces
in um
in shots so you can see people's like
different angles in the set when we do
the show at night so all the super chats
very helpful okay
now
guys
um
let's see
your wife gets to 200 leave leave her
that's actually not a lot for cameras
yeah it's um
it's like 2k a pop for cameras so i
forgot
my producer he just he gave me a budget
a lot of cameras that he wanted
we're gonna try to make it happen i want
you guys to see the producer too in shot
but
but yeah everyone liked the video um
we're at 175 people in here so i'd
really like to get this to about a 50
like ratio a like is free guys
not everyone has to donate but a like is
free okay help help uh help a girl out
um
but
i have let's see if i have this in the
chat
now
one argument that i've heard is some men
get their women fat so other men won't
look at the woman do you guys do that is
that a thing
i've heard that okay i've heard that i
you know if that's what you want to do
with your woman
don't don't involve me in that okay
that's that's not my issue
but if you're a girl
and you get
and you get pregnant and then you have
kids and you're double the weight when
he met ya
man that's disrespectful i don't know
what to tell you if he bought yet 200
okay that's another that's another deal
what does he expect
but but he bought you at 120 and now
you're 250 what you don't think the man
is supposed to feel some type of way
anyways um they all said no lazy woman
the math doesn't maybe you don't this is
just what someone told me on the show i
was like i have never heard of that
but
some some people are weird i don't know
let's see how many likes we're at we're
at 78 likes come on guys 100 likes 100
likes in here
that sounds like a lack of
accountability i agree
i agree
what else has gotten me in trouble with
the women um
hey
i can think of body count matters that's
another one that i talked about look
what we're not going to do in here
is i'm not going to tell you what you
should and shouldn't accept from women
you have the right to date whoever you
want but a man is entitled to not want
to date a girl who's done only fans
that makes you a less of a quality women
a guy is entitled to not want to date a
girl that's bang the entire football
team okay
guys this is a rocket science now i know
i know ladies a lot of us have been
given bad information maybe you had a
dad that told you go bang the entire
football team
i don't know
i don't know i don't know what your dads
were telling you
but
it does make you a lower quality woman
why now why
is this because historically men had to
ensure paternity
also cameras on
i gotta i gotta see your face i see
someone in the back room i need to see
your face
um
you are not a woman
no okay you're gonna get kicked from the
studio because i said girls
um
anyways
guys it's women only women only now one
day i will do a man call-in show i will
i will talk to you guys i used to do man
call-in shows all the time at like 20k
the real oh geez no the real oh geez you
know who you are
i just want to see if i can get a girl
on here i don't even know if any women
watch me
but if you guys have a girlfriend or a
wife
that's that's a feminist that you you
feel like needs to
talk to a girl like me or disagree with
me argue with me
send me
send me your women okay
you guys we gotta we gotta work together
on this because
i know what my analytics say it's like
10 girls
do we have girlfriends okay i would hope
some of you have girlfriends also
um the windows open and my dog might be
snoring during this lab if you hear
weird noises we're just dealing with
what we deal with out here
you have a girlfriend and no job i'm
with you there are some ladies okay
women women call and show it's only
women
at seven
7 23 in the morning now look i may have
to do this later i'm gonna give this
like
[Music]
how how long should i give it
to see if a girl calls in let's talk
about what else has gotten me in trouble
with the women
so
what else has gotten me in trouble with
the women oh oh i said modern women's
want to be victims
now what do i mean by this what i mean
is
when you talk to the modern women
nothing is ever her fault i'm under the
clear impression that if you get cheated
on it's your own fault you picked him
what did you expect
i've been cheated on it's not fun i
didn't enjoy that but it was my own
fault i cheated with him and if you
chose to stay
you don't get to cry toxic relationship
and abuse later
you really don't like
and that's what i'm saying
modern women want to be victims
they said they're still asleep you're
right i might have to do this later but
i'm in the uk guys
so
so you know
maybe i'll have to get up early
maybe i'm the modern woman because i
really don't like getting up early
[Music]
okay
oh situational femininity yeah either
you're agreeable or you're not ladies
look it
i'm an agreeable person
that's part of femininity it's being
agreeable there's parts of femininity
that i struggle with okay
i
i don't
i don't pretend to be on a high horse i
don't pretend to be better than anybody
i'm just trying to speak facts there are
girls that are more feminine than me
there's girls that are less feminine
than me but
you don't you don't get to situationally
change your personality that doesn't
make sense and so when men hear this
they're thinking
i don't want to deal with this crazy hoe
that's what they're thinking when you
say i'm situationally feminine i need a
man to make a
a certain amount of money in order to
submit like you're either a submissive
person
or you're not
no i understand not wanting to give
every man you meet the power to
completely control your life that that's
that's understandable okay i mean
there's some men that aren't competent
enough to do it that's that's that's
true
okay
however
you could still be a submissive and
feminine feminine
woman
you either are you aren't
it's okay if you're not
but then you know what you gotta work on
ladies we can't
we can't improve as women if we don't
identify problems
okay
last year i i looked in the mirror i was
like you're a little more thick than
slim
i i was looking in the mirror i was like
oh no oh no but but because
i didn't like what i saw and i did say
oh let's be body positive i was like no
i'm gonna get my ass to the gym a two
year later 20 pounds lighter
let's why are we
oh sorry guys um
i'll pin the let me see if i can pin
the
unpin my other comment
[Music]
and so let's let's talk about where do
you disagree with me where have i gone
wrong
where have i gone off the haywire
also
i have the link in the chat oh my gosh
okay
um
i'm trying to figure out guys
sometimes we have tech issues as content
creators
put it in the description oh i can do
that hold on let me
torsha you're smart
i literally guys i was supposed to do a
reaction video with someone and they
bailed they didn't show up
so
i was like you know what off-the-wall
call-in show let's just see how it goes
um okay i'm putting it in the
description
right now
okay
call
and link
okay i just added the link in the
description
okay
um
i'm i'm wait what does it say i'm a guy
but i disagree with girl
pearl being accepting of women having
toxic relationships with one another
excusing talking each behind each
other's back for example what when do i
excuse this
when did look it look it
here's here's the thing okay
i say that every every situation you're
in is your own damn fault
if you keep finding yourself in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
it's time to look in
it's time to
it's time to do some soul-searching if
you gained 100 pounds
in the past six months
it's time to look inside and say maybe
it's time to put the fork down
[Music]
that's
that's that's that's the whole thing
about my channel i don't really give you
guys advice either way
i'm saying give people the facts let
them do what they're gonna do
but what i don't like is lying to women
that's what i don't like
i don't like giving women
the
incorrect data facts and statistics
that's what's that's that's what pisses
me off
anyways
um
share to twitter
let's see i've been on for 15 minutes
ladies ladies let's talk
i promise i'm nice i promise
i promise
all right share to twitter i only have
like a thousand twitter followers so i
don't know if my twitter will really
help
um
i can i can try it though let me let me
see what i can do
um also guys get the likes up get the
likes up we got 500 people in the here
um let's let's get to 250 likes in the
chat
let's just let's be respectful you know
what a like is free it's free
tag
feminist
okay let's see
um
um okay i'm trying to get the link on my
phone because i don't know what my
twitter login is
god only knows
and it's not logged in on my computer i
only have like 800 followers on
but so hold on let me get it on my phone
let's see
okay i'm copying it now
um okay copied
um
i'll say here hold on
i'll say
come
debate me
hashtag feminists
and then i'll do
paste the link okay
i did it
guys there's there's 564 of you in here
not one of you has a [ __ ] you can send
me i mean a woman
um not one
guys
this is
this is not a smoke show this is ladies
having a discussion show
this is the ladies
the ladies having a chat
about what's reality
another thing okay another thing about
my channel that people get mad about is
going viral for the wrong reason they
come on my my show and they start
wilding out
wild and out
and they get mad at me for them going
viral
i'm sorry i'm sorry i have had
i built i've made a lot of people go
viral on my page for the right reasons
jess
almost 2 000 subscribers on youtube you
should go subscribe to her channel ally
she got like 20k in a week off of a
video i posted don't get me wrong you
need to be talented you can't you can't
do that unless you're talented
okay that like you won't do it i can put
you on my page if you're not talented
nothing's gonna happen
but what i'm saying
is that if you come on my page and you
start saying some wild [ __ ] it is not my
fault that i'm going to use that content
sorry
this is what did you think was going to
happen
jess is the best you all love jess
okay let's see
should i do these like weekly i should
probably i should probably get someone
to call in first
oh my gosh
you know what's crazy in the uk
they don't have air conditioning
it's so hot out here oh my goodness
anyways
um
all right ladies ladies ladies let's
talk
let's talk who disagrees with me tell me
what you disagree with me on
um two dollars you should debate simps
if no females show up i really want to
talk to the women today
because when you when you bring in the
men you get too many guys that are like
oh i just called to tell you we i agree
nothing wrong with that
we
will have that top that point in time
okay we will we will have that day it's
just not today okay ashley i need you to
turn your camera on
um
ashley so i need you to turn your camera
on because the re the reason being is
people wild out too much when they don't
when they don't have their camera on
and i'm just trying to ensure that we
have respectful conversation gotta turn
your camera on
oh i got another uh truda
camron
camera on is the deal
um
ten dollar super chat um
oh oh
oh we got one okay
let's see
all right you ready truda give me a
thumbs up if you're ready
okay
okay hi can you hear me okay
yeah can you hear me
i can't hear you can you guys hear her
in the chat it could be my settings hold
on this is the first time i've done this
let me check something
uh it says i'm okay can you guys hear
her
they say they can't hear you
um
yeah i don't know what the problem is
are you plugged in or your headphones
plugged in all the way
yes let me turn up my sound see if it's
on my end
okay wait talk again
hello hello
[Music]
yeah i'm sorry i can't hear you but i
don't you guys hear her
now she needs to speak into the mic
does this help
oh i can roughly hear you hold on let me
see something
okay wait um
maybe it's just because my headphones
are very old what is going on
hold on i'm sorry
let's see i think it might be on my end
because these are very old
speaker
the
let me try try it now
can you hear me
um
[Music]
dang
hmm
i'm sorry guys i don't know what
oh shoot i see the problem
oh no this is the dumbest mistake i've
ever made
it's the wrong headphones
hold on hold on
wait
wait talk again
can you hear me now oh my god i can't
sorry i thought this might have been my
fault
um hi your name's trudeau did i say that
right
how are you
i'm good can you hear me yes i can can
you hear me okay yes
uh so what do you disagree with me on
well i agree with you um on a lot of
things
one thing that i was wondering about is
the way that you think about men
cheating
i guess i have questions about that so
can you explain your stance on that so i
can see
okay so like in marriage
in marriage so
uh my stance on men cheating is that
cheating is different for men and for
women
so if a woman cheats she has more of an
emotional attachment than if a man does
so
to me if you have a child i would stay
if someone cheated because once i have a
kid it's not about me anymore personally
i wouldn't want to date a cheater
that's not that's not something i would
personally want to be involved with
because
um i do think like it comes down to
moral integrity and values but at the
end of the day i think it's your kids
before you
yeah i would agree with that um i guess
just
[Music]
um i am married and so
i would
like i wouldn't take it lightly still
and
um i guess basically still like there
wouldn't be an excuse for me like if you
are married then then you should
cheat like if you're if you want to
sleep around
and you want to hit
and of course things happen and it would
be a different situation
yeah um and the other thing was
um like
you're breaking up a little bit you're
breaking up a little bit i think it
might be your wi-fi is there somewhere
you can go or you're a little closer to
the signal possibly
no i don't think okay well i can't so um
if it's not working that's fine i i
don't have much more questions okay um
so what was the i i'm hearing you okay
now so what was the second part you had
a question maybe i just need to hold
this very still
okay yeah
um
so about like um weight gain and
marriage i do agree with you that
it's respectful to stay fit for your
partner oh and by the way i'm at work so
if i have to get off quickly that's why
okay okay that's fine
um but
i agree with waking in marriage like um
you need
to be respectful i think to do um you
need to stay fit and
and
not
get gross
but
um i one thing i heard which i kind of
agree with is
i feel like um your beauty standards or
maybe this is an idealistic way of
thinking about it but
i would wish that my my husband's beauty
standard would somewhat change from like
the newest hottest thing when we get
older to like
me staying as good looking as i can as i
age you know what i mean um yeah
yeah so um i would want there to be
grace for like i'm gonna get older and
if he's if he's only gonna think i'm hot
as a 21 year old then um
then it's gonna be rough when i get
older no see i think most men know we're
gonna age and know our bodies are gonna
change a little bit i don't think that's
an issue for most men like if you say
you know after she has kids she's gonna
gain 20 pounds most men are like oh
that's fine but it's it's the
i see fine girls that gain 50 100 pounds
before they've even had kids
and they don't take their husbands into
consideration at all
so the whole point is that we should try
to look good for our husbands we want a
man that
is worthless looking good for and that
we respect enough to stay in shape for
yeah yeah exactly and and i do have that
and so i would want to stay in shape for
my husband and i don't understand people
who um let themselves go as soon as
they're married so yeah i don't have a
lot of other questions and i don't want
to take up your time if um if there's
other people so okay thanks for calling
in you were the first you were my first
woman colin so this is exciting
okay and i don't really disagree with
you on a lot of things so
to be quite honest with you i like
accidentally joined
and i'm very surprised to be talking to
you so it's nice to talk to you i watch
you all the time on youtube
oh thank you and i didn't realize girls
ever watched me so it's nice to meet you
really
oh no it's like 90
is it really
oh yeah oh yeah
uh well have a good one thanks for
calling in
yeah have a good one bye
okay um zoey i i gotta i'm gonna you
were here first but i'm gonna let ashley
come in because she's got her camera on
um so if you wanna come on next you
gotta turn your camera on
hello
hey pearl how are you
i'm good how are you
i'm doing all right i apologize i'm a
little stuffy and um also i'm a recent
uh subscriber of yours i've stumbled
across you not too long ago i can't
remember what subject specifically and
honestly i don't know how long this
conversation is going to be because i
know i agree with you with a lot of
things but you're begging for people to
come on and i know there's been like one
or two things that i wanted more
clarification on you from because i
thought i disagreed but i'm sure if you
clarified i probably would agree and i
if i remember correctly
and
i might as well just ask you to
reiterate to see if i actually do
disagree
but when it comes to when you're talking
about the modern day feminism and when
you have women come on that
i don't need a man
and
you have a very strong stay-at-home mom
stance i think as far as the you know
the man can be the bread winner
that kind of thing um could you
elaborate more on
i guess the women that push back on that
as far as that not being their role
well i don't um i don't necessarily say
that like women should be stay-at-home
moms i say we give them all the
information and let them choose what
they're going to choose yeah
so what i have an issue with is feminist
lying to women and saying that a career
is going to make you happy and being
single childless at 50 is is going to
make you happy i think there are some
women that may be working part-time
works better for there's other women
that staying at home works better for
but i do think the woman has more of a
role in responsibility to raising the
kid than the man oh yes yeah well i
don't know
that's hard to weigh because as soon as
you say that i just know the huge role
that my
husband plays in my children's lives and
i don't
it's like saying that
almost downplays their part but that's
just because of the way society has
framed it and it's so annoying um oh no
you need both parents in the home for
sure yeah but i just think like women
it's better if you have the mom cooking
like being more in the home and the dad
like working in general more but most
people don't get the luxury of having a
stay-at-home wife they don't and
honestly people people have the
i feel like they put the blame in the
wrong place like
society and the way capitalism is it's a
machine and the way that women and men
fit into that machine it's going to spit
out a certain
you know
way that things come about so but people
will start blaming like the gender gap
and all that but of course you go into
the whole jordan peterson which i'm a
huge fan of him yeah he's great isn't he
he's oh my gosh i could if there's one
person i would fangirl over it's him
yeah yeah me too actually yeah
yeah so um
he completely has it right that you
gotta you gotta put in all the variables
as far as that but i guess to get back
so we don't just have a completely
agreeing conversation
um
i am curious and i asked in the chat but
i think you missed i don't know if you
want to get into religious things
because a lot of times
in my belief you know there's a lot of
underlying truth that will be put into
people who are non-religious as well so
as far as like
roles that women and men take you know
that plays a lot into the religious
realm as well and i i am just curious to
know your stance on how you feel about
women and leadership in in
in the church or that kind of thing
um i mean i grew up catholic so we
didn't have women in leadership yeah
we don't think we don't allow that
um i don't really have a strong opinion
on it either way to be honest
yeah i mean i don't i think men are
better leaders um and i think i would
more likely vote for men but i haven't
really thought about that one too much
to be honest because i grew up catholic
so it wasn't even like a question that's
funny you say that because i well i grew
up southern baptist
basically and i've kind of renounced the
whole traditional term and just say you
know i'm a follower of christ and i like
the non-denominational
but as far as i got into it with someone
one time with that because i also had
not realized i hadn't put much thought
into that because it was just kind of a
set understanding
um
but she did frame it in a way that made
me
look at it a different way which i
i guess i just had it in my head that
yes men are leaders that's kind of their
spot
as far as they're better at it not that
women can't do it
but for her she was kind of more all for
women being able to take that role
and i think when we broke it down it
came down to you know
we recognize we live in a broken world
and when
in a certain place if men
cannot
or
because we live in a broken world if we
have men that are not in place to be
able to take that that women kind of
have to take it upon themselves
to take that role
it's hard to explain but it was a very
interesting mind concept so it's like in
the end i i think men
are
the way their brains are wired in the
way that they
um ultimately should be lifted up they
are in the best position to be leaders
and then
women on the equal pedestal with them
are their best support
to
to be able to uplift them and encourage
them into that so
um
no i i agree with that um i mean i think
i always say i find that every good
business woman has a man behind her
even even me like i openly say i trust a
lot of my decisions to men because i
think they make them better
yeah well i feel like women can
overthink things but they're the wisdom
that they can have in the thinking
around everything can give the different
perspectives that men sometimes don't
see and i've seen that play out so much
in my marriage
like
you just you learn so much when you
marry someone it is ridiculous like we
are completely different people than we
are now and when the two become one kind
of it's like legit like you guys you
have to choose to love each other and to
this the whole submission thing too
people get so wrong like it's it's not
it's not submitting as if i'm weak or
the way jordan peterson puts it it's not
that tyrant tyrannical um duo it's
literally a partnership
to where if you're both you will
ultimately come across things that you
disagree on but one has to submit to the
other in order for things to move
forward and to move past those issues
and
you know if you want to
have that peace and a relationship and
that cohesiveness you have to submit
yourselves
to the leader and
you know in that in that role it would
be the man as far as so
how long have you been married
um oh gosh uh
i i think it's eight years this year
eight years might be nine years yeah and
we've got years two kids so oh you have
two kids yes
yeah
yeah
that'd be interesting to talk to you
about because my man like
motherhood
i know i from what i gathered you're not
there yet you're still looking for a
partner and then when you start that
family
it's a journey like it is no joke and
i'm so mad honestly i'm so mad at
society how much they downplay
stay-at-home moms that is
i think i admire that job the most now
that i've become a mother like
especially the ones that like stay home
in like home school
the amount of patience that would take i
have zero patience and i knew that going
in and i was like lord if you entrust me
with these children you know what i'm
like please you know give me good
children and he did and i'm still
incredibly impatient and i feel so bad
for it but
um that is one thing about society i
wish could change is um
the whole stay at mom's stance and it
makes me so angry um
at how much that seems to be pushing the
opposite direction
to where they're encouraging women to
like as you say to they'll be happy with
just the career and the dog and it's
like how can you compare like you you're
missing out on like your primal
thing that makes you a woman and it's
it's
are you
are you on tick tock at all
no
okay yeah
there's some there's so many women on
there that just are like coping
and you could just tell they're they're
clearly coping but it makes me mad
because they're marketing singleness to
younger women they're saying oh dating's
better dating is better in your 30s
well i might agree with that actually oh
really what oh my gosh devil's advocate
why because oh my goodness well
i feel like a lot of factors play into
that but
the mindset that i have now in my 30s
because i'm 34 back to when i was 20
like in my 20s and
it's like a double dynamic it's the
dynamic of the maturing process of an
actual person but then also playing into
the generation that you're in
so for me i'm like at the tail end i
guess of gen z is it ginger but you
didn't you didn't date in your 30s then
you were married
true i got married at 26. true so
i feel like i stopped aging when i was
like 25 so in my head i don't realize
i'm 34 but you're correct in that but i
was in my later 20s and it was weird
actually it was a huge jump between my
early 20s and my late 20s
because that's right when you're
finishing college and that kind of thing
you're dipping your toe in the real
world
um
but
as far as my early 20s and remember
generationally when i was 23 24. i
remember my mom saying that's when she
had me as a kid and i come from a
divorced family
so
i know
the crap relationship they had and the
reasons they did
and knowing the divorce right now is
like 50 which is insanity because people
get married off they get married off
emotions which are fleeting
um
but
anyway
you have to catch me because i'll ramble
on and on and now i'm completely
forgetting where the question we're
talking about we're talking we were
talking about submission and we were
talking about i was saying girls on tick
tock in their 30s they
like i it doesn't 50 of your options are
gone by the time you're 30. that's okay
so that's very true because of the
fertility
you know
yeah declines after 35 i think so yeah i
have a friend actually that's that's she
got married got divorced and now she's
my age and she literally has like
a year or two left to consider having
kids and she still doesn't know if she
wants it and she's like freaking out
about it
that's a lot of pressure to put on a guy
it is yeah
um
yeah and they're they're still learning
each other like you need to learn each
other and
that is the advice i would give if
you're gonna have kids like don't do it
within the first year your marriage like
you and your husband need some time to
become that partnership as much as you
think you've dated them for years on end
it's a whole other monster when you're
kidding
did you lo did you live together before
you were married no no okay i've i've
found the first like year of living
together is um difficult for a lot of
couples sure yeah
yeah that that'll make or break things
when you start realizing you know how
they like leave their toothbrush or you
know they realize that they leave their
clothes all over the floor shove it in a
closet that's what my husband found out
about me that was almost a make or break
but there's underlying it's not that
they're that shallow there's obviously
underlying issues there that you work
out to realize what you compromise with
your partner and that kind of thing so
yeah
well i appreciate you calling in it's
always nice to talk to married women and
so like on these platforms that not
they're not all the girls you see on the
internet are like crazy 304s because
i think there's a lot more regular like
normal nice girls than the manosphere
really gives credit to
but they don't they don't make we don't
make the best like entertainment right
we can't you can't you can't put modern
women humbled on that caption
no you can't uh no maybe i'll come back
on one day and i'll have the because i'm
dealing with wanting to be my inner
artistic self coming out so maybe i'll
come back with the rainbow hair and the
crazy look that you wouldn't expect of
me but right now i'm rocking the gray
hair and just trying to get enough sleep
so but i appreciate you having me on it
was really nice to meet you and yeah i
guess what i agree with i i think i just
yeah i don't disagree with you so sorry
for wasting the time of the actual point
of this chat oh no you're fine i was
good to have someone call him something
no problem all right bye
okay um she was that was a nice lady
ashley is a whole dub i'm gonna read
some of these super chats
let me put the camera here because
the read the chat is like on the right
wait let me
sorry
i do my best okay father's day is a day
but on sunday we are going to see the
single mothers are trying to take over
shut up shout out to all mothers on
father's day get the f out for the
coffee budget thank you
i should quit coffee to be honest i
really should but i love coffee i love
it so much
okay guys i've been on for 40 minutes
i'm gonna give it ten more minutes to
see if any girl calls in
to disagree with me
um
it's okay if not i i knew this was my
first show that was like not planned so
oh god
so you know you got to do do things with
work okay marriage evolved less to love
than kids and indifference resentments
roommates and then rediscovering hard
work and finally soul mates lust and
love and true partnership it's a journey
ashley didn't even make a point about
dating in her 30s i think she
misunderstood the question actually um
i keep telling myself to quit coffee
look
um
also guys colin not calling um tonight
we're doing a show we're talking about
only fans models and inflation so that's
gonna be nine o'clock tonight
do women even watch this show apparently
some
um
that's why kevin samuels did his shows
late at night 304s are awake well maybe
what time did kevin do his show
um love you from bk thank you
um five dollars pearl get out of the
simulation it's failing you
uh you will be stuck if you don't
jack point is running out okay dragon
stallion one zero zero one don't give up
coffee study people who drink any amount
of unsweetened coffee are 16 to
21 percent less likely to die early look
at the coffee i drink is not healthy and
i don't like black coffee
so
so you only do it 10 of easter and
that's like
12 1 2 3 4. that's like 4 am uk time
yo are you crazy
look at my
um
black coffee podcast pearl have you
considered tea
i sleep at 10 uk time
i'll think about it i will think about
it okay
um
matt as i said
um
i don't not men today i will do a men
call-in show
[Music]
would i marry a man that's not red
pilled
yeah i don't care
uh
j josh 40 you're taking that out of
context
but thank you for paying me so
um adwell george 8.99 thank you for all
that you do thank you
um
twenty dollars from sentience coffee
thoughts with all the wokeness have the
feminists swung the pendulum enough for
enough to drive the youth non-leftists
right back into traditionalism the left
will cancel everyone and everything into
their own opposition
probably i i i do think that every
generation is a reaction to the previous
generation
so
push it to 7 p.m u.s time 7
8 9 10 11 12. i could do a 1 am show
that's not too bad
that's not too bad
what do you think let me know in the
chat
what does my family think of my youtube
channel they don't really watch to be
honest all my family has jobs
no offense
um yeah they just like
they're not really that interested in
manosphere stuff
what if i did a post show
call in i could do that
okay
um
all right 46 minutes i'm going to give
it another until 50 minutes and then i'm
gonna i'm gonna head out
i'm gonna maybe do a couple reactions
pearl's dad stop calling me that's
exactly what he says should i call him
on stream should i call him on stream
hey pearl what demographic of men do you
find the most attractive handsome
what why are you asking me this what
what is this question for
what is this question for call my dad
i'll see
i'll see what he i'll see if he's he's
he's up
oh no this is my u.s phone i gotta get
my uk phone to call him
i wish i could interview my dad he
doesn't like social media
am i okay okay so i'm am i letting new
people come on the show um i typically
get people through instagram
occasionally email um
i prefer women so if you want to get on
the show if you can bring me women that
is the best way to get on the show
because women are much harder to recruit
this is the last week i personally am
recruiting after this you have to reach
out to my friend jess she's taking it
over
thank you jesus because i really hate
recruiting i hate it it's a lot of work
guys you have no idea
i i have i'm in the uk i have a uk and a
u.s phone don't you
anyways um
um
[Music]
what's my opinion on the consent laws in
spain i don't know what the consent laws
are in on spain
um
okay guys send me send me your women
send me your women
send me your women got five more minutes
five more minutes
[Music]
pearl why do you not do video interviews
most youtubers use stream yards so they
can get people all over the world in a
conversation um
i prefer in-person conversations i just
think it's a better interaction people
have to be nicer i just prefer in person
i've always preferred watching in person
content
it's just my my preference okay
now
i only have so much free time guys so if
i have the free time to go talk to
people on the street in london
or talk to people virtually i'm just
going to pick on the street
occasionally i might do once a week
call-in show but i just prefer like
bringing people in and talking to them
will you ever do a show from chicago two
dollar super chat um
we have played around we're playing
around with the idea if we get big
enough possibly doing a traveling show
but
um
we're not there yet we need to increase
like the revenue before we can get to
that point
so
somebody is in my
in the back room but your device says
device not it's connected and i think
jermaine that's a that's gotta be a
that's gotta be a boy name
um
first off
okay sir
it's quite odd for a grown man to come
into my studio
and send me
weird messages behind the scenes
that's a weird thing to do
okay um i don't know how old you are but
too old to be doing this i don't care if
you're 15 too old
um
thank you for the chat pearl
um let me know if you ever wish to talk
again i'd love to yeah thanks for
calling in ashley you seem like a cool
chick
um
timothy taubang thank you for the
content recently divorced and i'm slowly
becoming red pill
i find that some of the red pill
concepts are hard to accept
um would you do interviews in baltimore
maryland again i'm playing with the idea
of doing a traveling show i think it
would be really cool but
um
it's just at the time we don't really
have the revenue to do it do i have any
makeup on no i try to wear as little as
possible because it's really not good
for your skin
um
where are all the white boys at for red
pill combos and the flat are they too
scared guys i think you have to realize
where i live
is
it's more probable like i don't know why
one i don't know why people always bring
this up
but
like it's based on where i live okay um
curious um what equipment you choose for
colin um i have a road show
let's see
okay i'm avi your camera's off so i'm
gonna let kelsey in um kelsey
give me a thumbs up if you're ready
okay
hello hello how are you
i'm good how are you i'm doing well
so i'm a super recent follower uh okay
and i love your stuff
um i
i live in the midwest and i've been
super married for
oh geez
i think it's coming on seven years
but
but yeah i'm super stoked my husband's
the best
anyway
i
agree with pretty much everything you
say and i love all the
facts you give
my only complaint
is
the thoughts on like born again
christian virgins
okay whatever
the heck that means
um
i think
i think it just depends on where you're
coming from as a christian
um
but one
like in my
mind i've been a believer pretty much my
whole life but i've really gotten
serious in the faith
the last couple years i don't think
there's anything
there's no such thing as a born-again
virgin there's just not
like you don't
say that with murderers oh he was a
murderer
and oh but he's a christian now so it
doesn't count like it still counts a lot
and so
i don't know i just think that's
that's what people say
and i don't want to say that's what
people say when they're not really
christian
but i think you have to be far enough in
your faith where you realize that stuff
still matters
waiting what do you mean like waiting
until you're married yeah for sure like
you can't just join a church and
be like well that's the past right
yeah yeah so so the issue i don't have i
don't have an issue with people waiting
until they're married and i don't really
have an issue with people re-waiting um
if that's what they want to do
the issue that i have is that it's give
it's not taking it into account at all
what the men want
and often times and so it's it's letting
the girl fulfill her mating strategy
without at all thinking about what the
guy wants and oftentimes the only reason
the guy puts up with that is because he
doesn't have a lot of options
no i get i totally get that i mean full
disclosure my husband and i both waited
for marriage oh that's awesome
yeah that's so cute yeah no it it's
honestly one of the best decisions we've
ever made in my opinion and we dated
since i was 15. so like we waited a long
time
on my heart yeah
and uh
one
i guess i
my thing is just like
i want people to know that like even if
you join the church that doesn't really
change the past
like that's still like the past still
counts
i mean on a faith percent perspective
like you have to look at the world from
like
i don't know like god's perspective and
man's perspective like man is gonna see
that and say you know like all that
stuff still counts and yeah god if you
like truly accepted jesus
like great like and he sees jesus
righteousness in you but like man looks
at stuff different
so you can't just yeah count anymore
yeah well and and the issue is like men
are just frustrated when you've been
sleeping around from 16 to 27 and then
magically at 28 when you're running out
of time that's when the christians are
all of a sudden have found oh sure yeah
and so
the guys are like what the hell
no it's like i see that in my church we
have tons of single women in my church
you know a lot of times they have kids
you know so it's just like
i don't know
it's a tough situation
anyway thanks for having me on i just
want to thanks
thanks for calling in i appreciate it
yeah
have a good day thanks youtube bye-bye
bye
let's see
okay
guys okay
oh i'm sorry yeah
yeah
um what what is what's the
this is
okay hold on let me just end this stream
hold on
um okay guys hold on i have someone here
so i'm gonna go
um i will talk to you guys next time um
and also guys in the chat stop going for
people after their looks if they're nice
and respectful there's no reason to be
roasting them for their looks that's not
nice
it's rude
so
don't don't be going for their looks if
they're nice people okay if they're
they're coming at me one type of way
that's one thing but yeah okay bye guys